[Música]
de nuestro invitado del día vamos a
analizar lo que ocurre dentro de rusia
la economía de ese país cómo viven los
ciudadanos en medio de todas estas
sanciones y parte del bloqueo por los
países de occidente en respuesta a esta
guerra que inició el presidente ruso
vladimir putin el pasado 24 de febrero
ya son 50 días de guerra con sanciones
sanciones y más sanciones para ello por
supuesto está conmigo en el estudio añil
hablando nuestra periodista experta en
economía y quiero saludar en este
momento nuestro segundo invitado él es
ignacio montesdeoca periodista y
escritor ignacio gracias por estar con
nosotros en economía en pues en directo
américa de france 24 cómo están viviendo
entonces actualmente los rusos la
población civil en medio de todas estas
sanciones la vida cotidiana hablemos del
día a día
qué tal buenos días gracias por la
invitación y cómo están viviendo los
rusos los rusos están empezando a sentir
en este momento y cada vez más las
consecuencias de la guerra en sus
bolsillos es decir todo lo que la lo que
la propaganda no les permite conocer del
frente de combate les está entrando por
la bolsillos de la manera de un
incremento en la inflación una caída en
el empleo y por sobre todo una serie de
restricciones al consumo que se hacen
acá es más evidente en la medida que
está votando los stocks
horribles antes de la guerra
bueno se habla mucho de como el
occidente depende de rusia en materia
energética en materia también de
producción agrícola pero como depende
también rusia del resto del mundo que le
provee el resto del mundo este país
exacto
pagamos son unas vamos a cerrar unas
cifras para empezar a hablar el 75% de
los productos no alimentarios que
consume rusia proviene en el exterior y
en ese 65 el 60 y 75 el 60 robin en el
occidente es decir no es que en rusia le
vende solamente materias primas a
occidente a cambio consume una cantidad
inmensa para él su economía de productos
occidentales que son los que llevan al
mayor nivel de elaboración de manera que
las restricciones están pegando en el
consumo de bienes que rusia no puede
reemplazar desde
textil hasta un celular y son cuestiones
con la vida cotidiana y a veces uno
hablan de economía como una como algo
etéreo teórico pero en la vida cotidiana
y uno está en contacto con centro de
rusia nos están diciendo y empezamos a
notar que no podemos reemplazar
cuestiones son básicas para no solamente
para el confort sino para la
supervivencia
claro aterrizamos ahora ignacio la
inflación lo conversábamos ahora con
daniela blandón el caso de américa
latina pero los nuestros 50 días que
lleva ya la guerra y con sanciones
sanciones y más sanciones ya se habla de
un sexto paquete por parte por ejemplo
para hablar de un bloque de los países
de la unión europea cómo afecta la
inflación y qué tanto ha aumentado en
rusia en estos últimos días
y la última medición dio 1.17 lo cual
está elevando la proyección a de 18 el
año más optimista ni si tenía el mes
pasado más que significaba el 30 y ahora
más optimista arranca en 25 y termina en
40 y las proyecciones de estación tienen
que ver también con que con estas nuevas
sanciones y lo que se está pensando y
esto
para empezar a hablar es si occidente va
a empezar a sancionar a terceros países
o empresas que comercian con russians
sin que necesariamente ser rusas con lo
cual podría estrechar aún más el cerco
económico sobre ese país
y esto tendría consecuencias aún más
severas sobre la economía
señor ignacio cómo se vive el día a día
ya es decir hay desabastecimiento en los
en las tiendas la gente de pronto no
tiene con qué comprar cómo es ese día a
día
bueno esto me lo comentaba que empiezan
a faltar productos tan sencillos como
uno
campus para lavarse el cabello o un
repuesto para una computadora desde
empieza a haber una
alarma y una pérdida de confianza en la
economía que bueno se vivió los primeros
días cuando una corrida se retira los
1.400 me salen grandes del sistema
porque la gente se hace con efectivo
pero también se empezó a vivir en él
en materias primas muy básicas en el
empezó con el acaparamiento del azúcar
me contaban en rusia que de pronto todos
se empezaron a buscar azúcar y ustedes
dirán que tiene que ver bueno pasa que
el azúcar se usa para las conservas es
una costumbre muy rusa empezó a faltar
aceite porque los rusos dijeron bueno si
si en la cuenta agrícola hay nada de
observa falta el aceite los rusos
empiezan a vivir la vida cotidiana con
una idea de verdad economía de guerra
que está mermando en mucho la confianza
del consumidor sobre el futuro de la
economía y esto va a impactar en el día
a día y de alguna manera está poniendo
un manto de duda sobre lo que podría
como podrían llegar a responder la
población frente a las medidas internas
que está tomando por fin porque todos
sabemos que la economía es una ciencia
exacta pero en última instancia también
depende de la
produciendo consumidores empresarios
sobre la propia economía ignacio también
hablamos de un tema muy importante y es
del desempleo como está ahora el
desempleo en rusia recordemos que ya son
decenas de empresas las que se han
retirado del territorio ruso como parte
de este boicot de occidente para tratar
de decirle al presidente vladimir putin
pues para la guerra para que todo vuelva
digamos a la normalidad en su territorio
como ha afectado este retiro de empresas
a las personas que trabajaban en ellas
como que tanto ha subido a lo mejor el
desempleo en rusia
eso es muy importante para intentar
conseguir rusia en rusia el desempleo
llegó al 59 por ciento de su nivel no se
deriva de la guerra de crimea en el 2014
cuál es el problema con el retiro de las
multinacionales de la unesco solo con el
retiro hubo 125 mil puestos de trabajo -
ahora hay un millón de puestos de
trabajo que dependen de las
multinacionales muchas de estas empresas
se retiraron pero siguen pagando los
sueldos en tanto se resuelve la
situación si no se resuelve estas 125
mil empleos que se perdieron se van a
multiplicar porque van a dejar de pagar
esas plantillas que a veces siguen
pagando a la espera de una solución pero
además que el retiro de las
multinacionales tienen un efecto
multiplicador porque uno sabe que cuando
hablamos de relación hablan de l'oréal
pero a otra mentira pero al kolding se
pierden entre 4.000 y 7.000 empleos pero
qué sucede
l'oréal tenía una serie de proveedores
dentro de rusia entonces el cálculo
sobre los 125 mil empleos que se
perdieron de manera directa abarca otro
millón y por una fuerza de trabajo de 50
millones contra los millones estadios
trabajo porque ya no se pueden hacer
negocios con empresas que se retiraron
entonces ese 5.9 por ciento es altísimo
para reducida
qué son tres millones más de empleados
de desempleados se da además en las en
las regiones urbanas y suburbanas que es
donde tiene el mayor peso político
pública entonces es un problema de
desempleo también se convierte en un
problema político que se va a
incrementar en la medida que las
sanciones sigan actuando sobre la tasa
de desempleo también no solamente el
desempleo sino la pérdida del poder
adquisitivo hay estudios que dicen que
antes los hogares gastaban un 20 por
ciento de sus ingresos en alimentos
ahora gasta en un 40% en alimentos como
lidiar con esa situación lo que está
haciendo el gobierno para afrontar esta
situación
si hubo el poder adquisitivo y esto es
plato duro si bien la inflación subió un
11.3 en 1.13
desde que empezó la guerra los alimentos
subieron un 30% y algunos alimentos
mucho más 30% presionamos el caso del
sapu pero en el caso del té
no subas de hasta el 100% en el caso del
azúcar más del 30%
ahora qué es lo que está aquí lo que
propone este fin propone el compre
nacional o sea reemplazar esas
importaciones por productos nacionales
pero esto tiene un problema tiene un
problema que es muy severo que es que
una cosa es refinar azúcar otra
costumbre o si se querían moler el país
o el trigo para hacer
harina pero para fabricar productos un
poco más elaborados hace falta no
solamente en versión claro también knock
out y maquinarias esas maquinarias que
producen están repuestos necesitan la
hoja y cuando se retira las
multinacionales y de que retirase lonja
o se retiene esa eficiencia productiva
con lo cual producir cada cada bien
cuesta un poquito más eso contribuye a
la inflación pero además a largo plazo
lo que va a provocar es que ante la
falta de repuestos para una fábrica que
fabrica blisters para pagar el evento
farmacéutico son fábrica
en base al yogur eso va
haarde esa máquina deja de funcionar
porque hay que entrenar también otra
cosa no estamos en los años 40 las
maquinarias son muy complejas requieren
chips requieren circuitos requieren
programas que con las sanciones dejan de
llegar a rusia sí con lo cual los
productos tienden a encarecerse y te
traslade la inflación